the Joe Rogan experience it's at the end
of the world man is more to life than
fighting whoo it's funny hearing that
from you because you would expect to
hear that from someone who isn't
considered one of the greatest of all
time but you're considered one of the
greatest of all time so it would be very
art it would be very hard to argue your
approach because it's been so successful
they they they they got it baby
super obsessed I'm super obsessed Joe
but that's why I become crazy then I
stopped for four years then and when I
came back I some of my circuit and the
brain then I start to analyze myself and
I why I'm why become crazy what did I
stop because I'm taking this stuff too
seriously man you have to take it for
what it is you know I know it's a world
championship fight I'm fighting I was
fighting Michael miss me after four
years people oh my god the fight are
promoted on drama yeah and like John
said John Danner
he says I fight are not won on drama are
won or on mundane things than we do
every day
that's how fight are one yeah how you
program program your your your crews
your your your your crews driver you
know your your autopilot to win the
fight that's how you you may I see it I
fight like a autopilot you know like so
when I fight when I prepare myself for a
fight especially with a tactical part I
program like a computer ow
I want to react against that specific
problem oh I'm gonna take care that that
specific problem the only way to program
it is to do repetition repetition and
repetition and repetition and repetition
it's like you said at one point Eddie
Bravo we said like tie tying tying up
your shoes yes we've been doing it so
many time you can talk to someone the
same thing yes when I get into a fight
analyze again and I'm fighting and I see
what pattern he does the most often so I
want to program my computer to react to
that pattern that would give me the
advantage into the fight I don't know
what when that pattern when occur when I
want to program eyes
that when it a cure I have an answer for
it right away I don't have to think
about it I don't think I just react and
that's my problem when I used to fight
and I got a lot of criticism before I
was thinking too much towards the end of
my career I had so much pressure I
didn't perform as well as I was an
earlier he's pushing my last fight
before I stopped for the four years I
was thinking too much overthinking to
putting too much pressure like you said
it's too serious you have to take it for
what it is it's only a fight in a ten
years you know it's you know it's sucks
if you lose but man it is what it is you
know what I mean
don't take it for don't make it bigger
than what it is it's only a fight and
sometimes it's something very
therapeutic that I like to do before a
fight I Drive a car yeah when I fight in
Vegas for example I Drive a car or New
York same thing I Drive a car when I
used to fight in Vegas back before my
fights I used to be very very stressed
and want a very therapeutic things I
that I like to do is drive my car around
and see normal people then I go a note
about guys made to you why I Drive and I
see old lady with our grocery store bag
ha and I'm thinking like she doesn't
care if I win the fight Saturday or not
she's not even gonna hear about it then
I'll always another guy yelling to
another guy because whatever problem or
this guy is going to the bank to pay his
mortgage stuff they don't care they
don't care you know the effect that I
have on the universe is so freakin small
nobody cares I'm the only one putting
the pressure on me nobody gives a damn
about it so that's why they helped me to
perform now that's how some younger guys
say oh these I'm nervous how do you I
heard you don't sleep well the night
before I say yeah it's true I don't
sleep well what is your trick how do you
find a way to sleep well I was like I
don't really sleep well either nowadays
it is how I'll do but how do you feel
better about it like I just know that
I'm not gonna sleep well and it's not
gonna affect the outcome of the
competition it's just a normal thing you
learn how to deal with it better you're
not gonna change it yeah just accept it
yeah the stress is your friend and
that's gonna make you react there's
gonna be on the
have you ever slept well before I never
never only one time which one when I
fought Matt Serra and I got knocked out
and then after that knocked out I got so
scared and it happened again it's the
most humiliating day of my career I was
so angry like I said I was like putting
too much on myself it started there it's
like I didn't want go to buy eggs at the
grocery store because people this day
look you get knocked out like I thought
everybody cares about me nobody cares
about you nobody care it's only a small
percentage of population nobody gives a
damn and even if they do what you make a
mistake you you Zig when you should have
zagged you get clip so what everybody
make mistake you have to take fight like
it is you know it's a sporting event
that's why I don't take it personally
like it I wanna have the problem with
the Diaz but no problem and is that
fight it's not personal for me you're
you're in my life now you you won't be
there in ten years maybe maybe you will
man who knows it's only like a chunk of
life that we share together and then
after is gone no problem with that
[Applause]